so i was not um initially inclined to
talk about what's going on with uh milo
yiannopoulos
uh who is now saying he is no longer gay
he's now heterosexual
i i wasn't initially going to talk about
it but it's getting enough attention
and i personally had an interaction with
milo a couple of weeks ago and so i do
want to talk a little bit about it today
now if you're not familiar with milo
yiannopoulos he's a right-wing sort of
provocateur
who for a long time got plenty of
attention because he was
a gay conservative and he liked to say
that because he's a gay conservative the
left can't say all the things about him
that they would normally say about
heterosexual conservatives who are about
so-called family values and conservative
beliefs and on and on but ultimately
milo fell out of favor with the american
right wing
he supported donald trump you know he
did all the things that are the right
things that he
should have been doing but he fell out
of favor with them because some videos
came to light in which milo expressed
views about sex with underage
people that i won't repeat here but the
the comments were concerning even for
people on the right
who previously supported milo
yiannopoulos so milo sort of disappeared
and there were pieces written about him
about how he lost his career
and he lost his income and all of these
things and then milo reappeared
not long ago saying he has left
homosexuality
and he has fixed his life and has had
quite literally a sort of come to jesus
moment
now the exact wording around this
has to be looked at closely i don't know
if milo is being consistent in terms of
is he is he no longer attracted to men
or does he simply choose to no longer be
romantically
involved with men but he has the
attractions with all of this quitting
homosexuality stuff
these questions are always there and the
answers are rarely satisfactory i don't
know
and quite frankly it doesn't matter
because that aspect of the ex-gay thing
i'm pretty sick of but i'm gonna play a
clip where milo showed up on true news
not a program i'm familiar with that's
tru true news
and he said that as soon as he
became ex-gay dogs
stopped barking at him which he believes
is a sign from god
let's take a look when i made my
announcement the first thing that
happened
which will make you laugh but it's true
is dog stopped barking at me
i am one of those people you know
everyone's got that friend that dogs
always go nuts around
are you familiar with this right you've
got pets yes yeah right there's always
somebody that dogs
my dog doesn't bark at you i keep my dog
in there
but he doesn't mark you but that's okay
uh he like he bargains
people you must have some work left to
do um
that is true but but i was always one of
those
this sounds so stupid but this is just
how i think
that god reveals himself to us right
this is this is just
my experience of it i was somebody who
invariably
without exception always used to make
dogs go crazy
so we have a friend who's a political
candidate down here right and her
campaign manager has two of these little
yappy dogs and they would not stop i
couldn't be in her house for more than
20 minutes because it would drive
everybody crazy
even growing up we had alsatians we had
black labradors
um they just didn't like me at all
but dogs don't bark at me anymore and it
happened almost overnight now they seem
to quite like me and that sounds it's
the stupidest thing in the world
so there there's a lot there and i don't
know if other people have noticed this
but there's this thing
where when you're on a show like this
where i guess the hosts are devout
christians or whatever
no matter how one says god
revealed himself to them no matter how
stupid or bizarre
they always accept it and they nod and
they say yeah
yeah milo says you know this might sound
stupid
but i believe god revealed himself to me
and is sending me the message that i was
right to quit homosexuality
by making dogs no longer bark at me oh
that's great that's
you know god god reveals himself to us
in different ways actually that's
idiotic that's
absolutely ridiculous why would god
communicate in that way it makes no
sense oh well but god works in
mysterious ways
like through dog barks oh okay well then
i guess that we can't touch that
that so it's an unassailable comment
then now my real comment
my real concern here is two different
things
first of all the damage that this ex-gay
quitting homosexuality stuff can do to
young
lgbt individuals who might see this or
hear about
milo quit being gay as if it's like a
hobby
and thinking that that's something they
could do or something that they should
do
everything we know is that not living as
oneself
is not a good thing emotionally and
seeing this
might plant the idea in other people's
minds that this is this is something to
be
pursued or even to be applauded to to um
what what milo is doing when it's not
the second concern is
remember milo was pulled out of the
public eye after being shamed for his
comments about sex with underage kids
this entire thing to me seems like an
attempt to link homosexuality with
pedophilia
and that's why all these shows are
having milo on to cheerlead what he's
doing because remember here
what's the framing the framing is milo
used to be gay and he was gay when he
said this stuff
about sex with underage kids now he
found god
now he's heterosexual and so now it
helps to
distance himself from those things he
said it's an
a pathetic attempt to link homosexuality
in pedophilia which is another old
homophobic trope
so i invited milo to come on the show to
talk about all this
i said you're welcome to come on i would
love to speak with you about this recent
announcement
and he wrote me back and he simply
declined he said he's not interested in
that
and based on the shows i've seen him do
lately it seems he's interested in
the type of interview he got on true
news that's fine
that that's fine this is not me on a
power trip saying how dare he
decline being on my program when we are
so much bigger than true news
i it's i understand why he said no to
this show he would actually have to
answer or at least
be asked he wouldn't have to answer it
would be up to him he would actually be
asked real questions on this program and
to me this seems more than anything else
an attempt
to regain relevance and get attention
once and again the invitation to milo
remains open
welcome on the program anytime one of
our sponsors
is vincero watches giving you 15
off a high quality wristwatch is the
perfect way
to elevate your style own at least one
watch
that makes you feel great when you put
it on you can often see me wearing
my ventura watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six
thousand five star reviews and they
stand behind
every watch they make with a one-year
return policy and
five-year warranty they'll give you 15
off everything in their store and free
shipping at davidpakman.com
watch use the coupon code pacman